what's happening reject nation gregg al
Bahia I'm John we are going to watch an
honest trailer that I'm very much
looking forward to every Christopher
Nolan movie well I love the screen
jockeys take on every Wes Anderson movie
and we said in there that we were hoping
they'd do more of these director cuts
Christopher Nolan's when you could
definitely do
oh yeah he's gotten your marks man I
also wanted to mention too I just got
invited on movie fights for this week
it's not 100% confirmed yet but I'm
supposed to be going on movie fights
this Thursday it's live I'm nervous
last time I was on it I omit I didn't do
that great of a job at good picks not
good arguments I've seen countless movie
fights since then I am ready to compete
on that show don't know who I'm going up
against or what the topics are yet as of
filming this video but I'm really hoping
you guys to tune in and show some
support show some love vote for my
choices just as I'm asking you to tune
in anyway let's watch this video in the
meantime one two three because of your
contributions to our Women in Film
charity event you were locked in honors
trailer for every Christopher Nolan
score first knew him as the guy who made
memento then he was the guy who saved
Batman now revisit the retro actively
perfect films of the Internet's God of
cinema makes sense cuz only God could
get The Dark Knight Rises go to the 66
been sued uh very literally with
Christopher hanwen a visionary director
whose actual vision is red-green color
blind which explains why so much of his
work as tinted blue
as he carefully constructs a series of
intricate puzzle boxes full of nonlinear
storytelling no no technical wizard wu+
that range from holy crap that was
mind-blowing - holy crap that blows have
a house of musical scores that will make
you scream
what I can't hear ya
[Music]
a Christopher Nolan protagonist he's a
well-dressed white dude with rush back
hair kind of like Christopher Nolan was
intense stoic man who's a criminal or
vigilante it still follows their code at
the same posted twice never show anyone
never recreate places for memory always
imagine new places
interstates with a tragedy of his past
whether it's the death of his wife I
remember my wife time the death of his
wife taken of his wife the death of his
wife
and the doctors put him under cyst in my
wife's brain because grieving characters
the dead of his no one really wants to
shake things up the death of his
girlfriend
that's a lot of dead wise what could it
don't mean the other person anything
about you is that you work with your
lovely wife Emma films that race cold
and remote as the icy Tundras they
feature where human emotions aren't so
much felt as reason about I think
positive emotion Trump's negative
emotion every time love has meaning yes
social utility social bonding child
rearing a summation for died where's the
social utility in that and where time is
just a toy to be played with whether the
stories told out of order backwards and
forwards simultaneously through an
interlocking series of flashbacks in
three separate levels of a dream where
time moves at different speeds in space
where time is relative or in World War
two where time has just sort of mashed
up to make things more suspenseful and
if you think it's all too complicated
I'll let no one break it down on a level
you babies can understand that's
basically the end of the movie this
stuff is the black and white stone this
is running backwards you have flashbacks
to a different timeline some of which is
color somewhat retraction wind of the
film being there relate to a parallel
story see couldn't be simpler so if you
love cinema and enjoy being wowed by a
true auteur cheer for a man who's
rightfully considered one of our
greatest modern cinematic I incredibly
talented pool of actors and obsessive
dedication to the craft of filmmaking
have given birth to a rabid fan Polly
that will ignore all the nice things we
just said and focus on the joking
nitpicks
which will be taking 100% seriously I
mean he's one of the best filmmakers
working today
okay is that not enough why so serious
[Laughter]
things this company went public a week
ago and I bought most of the shares
I bought the yellow so let's put a
couple tables together I'm not sure that
they'll let us all they should own the
place
clunky exposition oh yeah it's late were
you type in someone's name date of birth
and a few minutes they're gone every
database on earth now we're trapped in
fishes man battling his own private army
and if we get killed we'll be lost in
limbo to librarians tend to scramble
Dave you're a well-educated man cool a
trained pilot and an engineer though
mask as I see my mask
you're wearing a mask just take up that
mess you just take off your little
matchsticks like putting on a mask if
you're working alone no one cared who I
was and I put on the mom's okay
[Music]
crowd
Tesla trades
yeah it's a very emotional Michael Caine
no and it also means losing someone I
have cared for since our first birdies
cries echo Brutus house don't you
[Music]
it makes a big rush okay I'm sure you
all know about the first letters in the
characters names an inception spelling
out dreams but did you know that all the
astronauts initials and under stellar
spell out B are CMD which can only be a
reference to the TV show doc where Billy
Ray Cyrus plays an MD and his
character's name was Clint
Cassidy see see that has to be reference
to Charlie Chaplin who was good friends
with E to the P ah the singer the song
an inception that's the cue for
everybody wake up you know makes perfect
sense we're gonna dream man no let's try
to wake yourself hurry before it's too
late
the table just keeps spinning I have to
wake up why you be eating it by foot
fees poor job sandwiches earlier my
morality is the best movie in all of
history even better than the Dark Knight
I have a not so okay feeling about this
great stuff here screams oh he's great
stuff I mean there was some like obvious
ones that are nitpicks
I thought there was quite a few things
that were like well those are just
within the Batman was just like well
that's all primarily Batman they're
talking about the rich guys like a lot
of that's like the Batman films too you
know
it's a yeah sweet lines I thought this
one was was still really clever and
maybe not as deep as like the Wes
Anderson cuz Wes Anderson has a more
like out there and vivid style yeah I
feel like snow ones maybe a little more
subtle than that
yeah but there are some still great
things they pointed out here I love
their thing about every main characters
a white male protagonists look back here
kind of like Christopher Nolan yeah a
tan suit I didn't think that white thing
I never picked up on that's one thing I
love about what the screen junkies do
here with ease is they're funny there's
still an honest trailer but they're also
like film school ish yeah which I feel
like you're learning something here
about what makes their films work even
though they're making fun of them and in
a way mocking it saying these Uzis
repeating some tropes at the same time
it's a big part of what makes his films
work because they're not it's not so in
my face that I took note
oh yeah it was like a dead wife and all
yeah yeah well that's you know these are
the earmarks of an auteur style and and
I kind of hope I mean I know these were
like reach goals for their fundraiser
but I kind of hope they keep doing these
these are some of my favorite honest
trailers actually when they break down
somebody's hold them on yeah there's one
thing I know that no one likes to say a
lot in his movies which is that's more
like it
Don Cobb likes to say it an inception at
one point to Ellen Page Jonathan crane
says that crane yeah Dark Knight that's
more like it
it's a third movie I can't remember what
one it is but I remember I like noted
this a while ago that's like it is a
repeat line
in a weird way looking at this actually
made me appreciate Dunkirk more because
doctor it's not my favorite film of his
but it's the one that's least filled
with his typical tropes yes nothing you
know yeah other than that I like the
landscape shots or whatever the
beautiful use of the IMAX camera
surprised I didn't really talk about
that I used to the IMAX cameras cuz he
was like the one who brought that
sunlight to mainstream so one handedly
brought the actual format
yeah not just to blow up because the
dunker doesn't really have in-depth
characters and a lot of this is making
fun of the types of characters that
there are here hey man they were
probably a lot of dudes who lost their
wives at Dunkirk yes sure I have to
imagine half woman who are secretly evil
is a great carry a moss yeah they have
that line here about emotion is not so
much felt but reasoned about where human
emotions aren't so much felt as reasoned
about that is actually a criticism I've
heard about Nolan's films before his
movies are emotional but they're also
like this observant piece of emotions in
some way yeah yeah there's something
where they don't like translate visually
the characters emotion but they're not
devoid of like catharsis it seems like
the leads aren't always the most
emotionally expressive carrot no no no
but there's always he makes kind of
romanticized movies I feel like there's
always an element of you know the human
spirit or love yeah I think that's how
he gets away with some nitpicks the
Michael Caine ending in The Dark Knight
Rises for example Allah be able to point
today's like a really corny moment and
kind of ridiculous and wise Bruce Wayne
there when he should be in hiding
analogical observation there's a lot of
flaws but his films are not really about
logic sometimes even that moment it's
like kind of a poetic moment REME almost
yeah and it's a fairy tale that way and
it's all within his tone and that's how
he can get away with stuff like that I
think Dark Knight Rises had a more of an
issue with escaping that because of the
logical rule set up by the prior
installments yeah because that one Dark
Knight Rises is very much like you got a
little like watch it go for certain
situations that movie yeah
in a weird way I almost feel like I mean
there are some intense emotional moments
in all of his movies but in in ways I
feel like Dunkirk is maybe his most
emotional movie because the whole scope
of the plot is just people who are
exhausted and want to get home so you
can kind of feel that on everything
there's not so much so like oh this
characters really slick and that
characters really closed off it's sort
of everyone's thrown in this one
situation the exposition to the
exposition for sure I mean it's kind of
needed yeah the thing about like you
watch inception if there is no
exposition I just see sitting there ya
know what it's happening he does make
plot II movies I guess I hadn't yeah
vocally thought about that but I think
that's why his films kind of go hand in
hand with that whole observation of
emotion cuz he's trying to like yeah
conveying the point home especially in
his bigger films I mean like that line
from Dark Knight Rises is very
expositional when it doesn't need to be
yeah my only my only gripe with pulling
that particular shot is I think the very
next line is sound a little too good to
be true
so I'm like in that context have a
little more forgiving but there are a
couple other shots they pull they're
pretty on the money for them needs to be
yeah we're gonna be confused yeah he's
one of those filmmakers where I get it
because there's so much going on this is
important I guess it's better that we
know for certain obvious to keep on what
the hell is going on I would actually
not like you different there was an
exposition yeah yeah and I mean some of
that stuff being thinly veiled I can
forgive and a last thing is I love their
line about you know how audiences will
stick to the nitpick jokes that they
make here yeah find ways to ding him
when he really is in fact one of the
best filmmakers around cuz he is that
filmmaker that I feel like more and more
people are trying to take down now yeah
I feel like if anybody gets loud 'add
too much and is regarded with too much
cloud or whatever you know people are
gonna start picking out where their
faults aren't hey man he's not perfect
filmmaker there's stuff that he could do
better there's stuff that could be more
well-rounded about his movies especially
now that he's gotten so huge they can
kind of do whatever he wants but I feel
like especially for a filmmaker of his
caliber there's a lot more good in his
tool belt than not
yeah sure and I mean every film he
releases practically is distinct at the
very least yeah I think another trophy
has to is like he does a lot of
intercutting montages yeah I'm surprised
at input like they talked about the time
oh yeah when you got a lot of like an
ensemble piece yeah a lot of people are
doing stuff at once there's a ton it's
in the dark night too when the mayor's
being poisoning the Joker's invading
you're looking for Harvey Dent he does
these intercutting and it's like it's
handheld and then he'll switch to like a
smooth shot there's a lot of detail
things about his work but they wanted to
stick to things that are probably funny
- yeah that's not something you really
make a joke about all right guys well
every Christopher Nolan movie right here
a great job honest trailers man you guys
are great hopefully I do go home movie
fast this Thursday a little nervous but
I got to redeem myself you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification will get notified
every time when our vids is up and I can
check us on patreon full-length TV show
reactions weekly Q&A x' music video
coverage we love to have you become a
patronage act today